our lives are full of decisions both
professional and personal
where it gets interesting and
potentially tricky is when both are
professional and personal Decisions
Collide
today we'll learn how communication can
play a critical role in helping navigate
these issues
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
foreign
to chat with Myra strober and Abby
Davison Myra is a labor Economist and
professor emerida at Stanford University
where she was among the first female
professors at the GSB she was the
founding director of the Stanford center
for research on women now the Clayman
Institute for gender research Myra
studied gender issues in the workplace
in the economics of child care
Abby is a social Innovation leader and
career development expert she holds
master's degrees from both Stanford
Graduate School of Business and
education Abby served as president of
the Gap foundation and co-founded the
company's employee Resource Group for
parents together Myra and Abby just
published their new book money and love
an intelligent roadmap for life's
biggest decisions welcome my right Nabi
thanks for being here I am super excited
for our conversation well thank you so
excited to be here great let's Jump On
In One Way We Define Our Lives is
through the professional and personal
decisions we make we often get advice to
not let money concerns influence our
decisions about love and never to allow
love to influence our decisions about
money
Myra your new book is titled money and
love I assume you've thought about this
advice and and might have some opinions
on it is it good advice no it's not good
advice at all
separating money and love is not a good
idea I have had about 40 years to think
about this and in my class at The
Graduate School of Business on work and
family each semester I realize how
important it is to intertwine love and
money love decisions
although people fight against this
sometimes love decisions do involve
money if you want to know who to marry
if you want to know how many kids you're
going to have all those decisions
involve money
and money decisions involve love when
are you going to retire are you going to
have enough money to retire what career
are you going to pursue and how's that
going to affect the rest of your family
all money and love intertwines
so we have to consider both when we make
our decisions you do
so Abby you and Myra provide a five-step
framework to help us make complex
challenging life decisions can you share
this framework and explain why is it so
helpful how does it work
well no two decisions are alike as you
said they're complex they're thorny and
so we wanted to create a flexible but
sturdy framework that could be applied
to a number of different life decisions
is this the person I want to spend my
life with do we want to have kids
together do we want to continue pursuing
our careers while we grow our families
all the way through how do we care for
our aging relatives so our framework has
five steps and I'll talk about them at
the high level and then we can go deeper
in a couple of them so clarify what's
important to you communicate
with the people involved I know that's a
near and dear to your heart think about
a broad range of choices check in with
trusted resources and consider the
consequences
I love that it's easy to remember five
C's and as those who listen to the
podcast know I'm a big fan of Frameworks
and structure so I do look forward to
drilling down a bit and and of course I
want to drill down on the communication
step of your framework Myra you both
recommend opening up a two-way dialogue
with those involved in the decisions we
are contemplating
do you have advice on how to initiate
these conversations I can imagine that
this can be very difficult if the
decisions were contemplating run counter
to the expectations the other folks
involved have for example delaying
marriage or starting a family seeking to
move to another job or a location what
advice can you give us
well the first piece of advice is don't
startle the person that you're about to
communicate with you know you've just
finished dinner one of you is still
clearing the dishes off the table and
all of a sudden you say I'm thinking
about a new job that's not the best way
to communicate much better is to say
there's something really important I
want to talk with you about can we carve
out a little bit of time tonight or if
not tonight can we spend some part of
Saturday talking about this that would
be my first piece of advice on
communication
that's really helpful my wife and I
often joke that we both do this to each
other we're so busy during the day we
don't have time to think so right as
we're going to bed we're like oh yes we
need to talk about this and we both feel
relieved that we got it off our chest
whatever it was but then the other
person lays awake at night staring at
the ceiling thinking about what do these
mean so taking the time to be thoughtful
about when you have the communication
really very very important thank you
we've talked about that a bit when we
talk about giving feedback as well the
timing of that is really important
so Abby when it comes to your checking
in Step what guidance can you provide on
how we can get honest and helpful input
feedback and advice from those who are
close to us I fear that our closest
friends and family might simply tell us
what they think we want to hear rather
than what they really believe
it's a good point and and part of it is
actually how you frame the check-in step
so it's one thing to go to a trusted
friend or resource and say what do you
think I should do and that's not what we
advise it's very helpful to hear
examples of how other people have
approached these decisions so if you're
trying to decide what type of job you
should take you can ask someone how did
you think your decision about your
career or for example when my husband
and I were trying to decide whether to
move in together after we graduated from
the business school we talked actually
we did research for our final paper in
Myra's class and talked to four other
couples who had lived together before
they got married three of whom had
successful outcomes and were still
together and one who wasn't and we
checked in with them about their
approach how they thought about finances
and that helped us inform our own
approach
so how you frame the question really
matters and then doing some Focus
grouping it sounds like and going out
and testing or checking with those
who've been through that before can be
helpful certainly that's really good
advice I need to make sure that I I
remember that I find myself often in the
moment so so impacted by the emotion I'm
feeling or the worry or concern I have
about the circumstance that I often am
not as rational as as I think your
framework suggests we should be and I
think that's really helpful to pull
myself out from that well it's human
nature I mean these are such big
decisions we're so in it we don't like
uncertainty as a species and so we want
to get to the other side of the decision
as fast as possible sometimes but what
the framework does is provide an
approach that helps you slow down your
decision making and gives you a way to
feel more confident that you're covering
all the bases before you get to the
other side yeah that pacing and
perspective I think are really important
and I appreciate that in the framework
you've provided
we've talked about conflict influence
and negotiation many times on this
podcast but I'd love to get your take on
ways to navigate some typical life
decisions that many of us face so Myra
I'm curious what guidance would you
provide couples considering marriage and
or having children
communication
they think about talking
and they think about what they're going
to say
and they forget that the other half of
communication is listening
quietly and carefully and attentively
and especially for tough decisions the
first step of our framework is clarify
so before you get into the communication
you want to be clear on what it is you
want but then you want to learn what the
other person wants
and hopefully if you and the person
you're communicating with have done this
frequently each of you knows that the
first step is to clarify your own
beliefs
beliefs wishes whatever it is
as the communication begins you might
say to your partner you know I think
maybe before we talk about this it would
be good if you went back and thought
about this by yourself
okay so now assume both of you have
thought
this is like a dance
so now you both come to the dance and
you're ready to
clasp hands and Waltz around the floor
and now
you may each change your mind as a
result of listening to the other person
so then
you have to go back and clarify again
and maybe your partner has to go back
and clarify again then you come together
so this requires patience
this is an ongoing communication about
very very critical issues
I really like that metaphor of a dance
because for a dance to be successful and
enjoyable both people have to work
together and although I don't have
really good Rhythm nor am I a good
dancer you really do have a pace and a
timing for things and I appreciate the
advice to be clear on what it is you're
asking for and to be patient I also
heard you say you have to be willing to
be adaptive and change as you learn more
information
really really helpful
so Abby let's change more to talk about
career how should we be thinking about
proposing a major career change with our
partner I'm thinking about things like
quitting a job moving to a new location
taking on more responsibility and more
work time how should we think about
those situations
the first thing to realize is that those
decisions if you're in a relationship
maybe you even have kids or other people
living in your household that your
career decisions are going to affect the
whole ecosystem and so it's very
important not just to clarify what you
want but to anticipate and think about
the impact on the others around if
you're about to take a job that requires
extensive travel that is a huge impact
on the other people who will have to
pick up the slack when you're not there
so it's critical to engage in these
conversations in a way that provides the
space for everyone to voice their
concerns their hopes their dreams and I
find personally that getting out of the
day-to-day so actually leaving the house
with the piles of laundry and the dishes
in the sink is really critical my
husband and I have had really important
conversations actually both just made
big career changes and some of our best
conversations that led up to these
changes happened on Hikes so we would go
out on the weekend we'd let our kids run
ahead of us I remember one conversation
where he had just left his job as the
CFO of a tech company and he was getting
head hunted by recruiters for other CFO
jobs and he said I don't know I'm
getting these these calls should I
should I take them and and I think he
kind of expected me to say sure go for
it but I said I don't know do you want
that it doesn't you know based on what
you've shared before it doesn't seem
like that's something you'd be too
excited about he said you're right it I
feel dread when I think about taking
those calls and so if he kind of I guess
the lesson there is don't assume that
the other person is going to react one
way or another but being in a natural
setting having the space and ability to
think broadly about it was so important
to us making those big moves for our
careers well and congratulations to you
for making those moves what I'm hearing
is perspective matters your perspective
considering everybody else who's engaged
or involved in these circumstances I
like the ecosystem model that you talked
about but also being open to somebody
else's perspective in that communication
not just expecting they're going to say
one thing versus the other and place
matters I I love that you do a lot of
your your intense communication outdoors
and Hikes I think it's hard to be
embedded in the environment where you
have your day-to-day routine to talk
about things that are not day-to-day or
routine so thank you for that
many of our leaders are managers and
leaders and organizations Abby what
advice do you have for them to better
support their employees work and
personal relationship needs
well managers have such a tough job
right now they are balancing a lot
they're managing up they're managing
down they're managing sideways and a lot
of them are burned out
I think it's really critical for
everyone but particularly managers to
think about the whole person and how
what's going on in their life outside of
work may affect what they need to be
able to do their best work and ask
questions create an environment where
they feel comfortable bringing up some
of those needs so that you can
best create the conditions to support
them and I'll give you an example in my
job at the Gap
we ran a program called This Way onward
that helped young people with barriers
to getting jobs get a foot in the door
and Away in and Away up into the
workplace and there was one store
manager who hired a young man and he was
late to every shift and she could have
just fired him and said you know what
this didn't work out but instead she got
curious and she said hey I've noticed
that you've been late to every shift can
you tell me a little bit more about
what's going on and he said you know my
dad works the overnight shift my mom
passed away and my dad really depends on
me to get my younger brother to school
and I have to take two buses to do that
and then they take the bus back and then
by the time you know the last bus leaves
I I can't be here for the start of the
shift and she said oh so if we shifted
your start time a few hours would that
be better and he said yes and then he
became her star employee and so that
example illustrates that rather than
having a knee-jerk reaction and just
saying you know this isn't working
getting curious and finding out what's
underneath some of the challenges could
have a really transformative impact I
think the advice for managers to be
curious is really powerful
and the other thing I heard you say is
you have to set up an environment where
people feel comfortable sharing what's
going on in their personal lives in the
workplace because many of us don't and
it is incumbent on leaders and managers
to help people feel safe and comfortable
doing that
I wish I when I was younger had more
managers that did that don't we all yes
yes
before we end I'd like to ask you both
the same three questions I ask everyone
who joins me are you up for that sure go
for it all right here we go so Myra will
start with you
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
listen
and tread lightly
we heard you mentioned those a little
earlier and I can see how important they
are so listening is is very clear and
that has become more and more of a theme
on this podcast about communication is
how important listening is can you
remind us and give us a little more
detail on the treading lightly
well this example comes from my class
actually
there was a fellow in the class who had
a lot more business experience than most
and we were talking about maternity
leave we hadn't yet
come to the world where we talked about
paternity leave but this was maternity
leave and he was very proud to say that
when he was a manager he encouraged all
of his women who employees who came to
him and said they wanted maternity
leaves to take the longest maternity
leave possible and that he would go to
bat for them and get them the longest
maternity leave possible
and one of the women in the class who
was not shy
said I'm glad you were not my manager
I don't want a long maternity leave I
want the shortest maternity leave I can
possibly have so I can get back to work
as soon as possible
he was shocked
and in the course evaluation he wrote
that this was the most informative part
of the class for him and he realized
that he had to listen
that he couldn't just assume that his
employees wanted one thing or another
and so I think the listen part is so
important right and then the what I hear
in the tread lightly is you can assert
or you can ask right and and by asking
it's a little more tentative and you can
learn more from that and that's that's
really powerful
so I'd like to move to question two and
we'll start with you Abby who is a
communicator that you admire and why
uh well I am a big Peloton person and so
for me Robin arzan who is the first
instructor and now does a lot more at
Peloton is very impactful she's
authentic she's confident and she makes
me feel really good about myself when
she's making me work real hard so a lot
of inspiration and motivation of all the
people we've talked to and asked this
question of nobody has mentioned a
Peloton instructor but they are
absolutely motivational I have done some
Peloton and I absolutely agree very good
communicators Myra can I ask you the
same question who's a communicator that
you admire and why
well my answer is probably more common
I admire Oprah
I love to watch her interviews I think
she
she really listens and she takes people
wherever they're at
and makes you understand that it doesn't
matter whether you agree with the person
you're interviewing or not you need to
help the audience understand where that
person's coming from she does that she's
vulnerable she talks about herself she
lets you know about herself
she asked great questions
she's she's my model
amazing Communicator for sure in my
strategic communication classes will use
her as an example the part there that I
want to highlight is
she connects the audience to the people
she's talking to and that's really
really important in communication
thank you all right our third and final
question Abby what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe
I think the conditions are so important
to the idea of getting in a place where
you are physically able to communicate
emotionally mentally all of those pieces
really matter to set up a good
communication
the second I would say is to give grace
to the other person that you are talking
to don't make assumptions tread lightly
give them the benefit of the doubt and
then the third I think is to have
patience these big life decisions don't
need to get solved overnight and it may
take a number of conversations and you
might have to come back to the topic
because things are getting heated and
that's okay good communication doesn't
always look pretty and elegant it can
get messy and awkward and uncomfortable
and that's real but having faith that
you'll get to the other side of it
together is important to the recipe
so many important things there what I I
took away immediately was this notion of
good communication can be and in some
cases should be messy and from that you
can get some honest really clear results
and the in the idea of making sure
you're in the right place and that you
give yourself and your partner Grace
really really important this has been
phenomenal thank you Myra and Abby your
five C's framework is incredibly helpful
I'm already thinking about how I can
apply it here in my work but also at
home I've got a wife I've got teenagers
I've got aging parents this framework
can be really helpful not just for me
but to everybody listening and I wish
you great success on your new book money
and love an intelligent roadmap for
life's biggest decisions thank you
thank you
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn
[Music]